si se le ha diagnosticado niveles altos
de colesterol a usted oa alguien que
conozca es importante que comprenda que
colesterol es y por qué es importante
que lo mantenga bajo control el
colesterol es una sustancia similar a la
grasa producida por su hígado pero que
también proviene de alimentos que usted
ingiere luego una vez en su organismo su
hígado lo agrupa en pequeñas partículas
llamadas lipoproteínas
su cuerpo necesita colesterol para
producir hormonas vitamina d y una
sustancia que lo ayuda a digerir
alimentos llamada bilis
este vídeo describe dos tipos de
lipoproteínas que contienen colesterol
lipoproteína de baja densidad o
colesterol ldl también conocido como
colesterol malo y lipoproteína de alta
densidad o colesterol hdl también
conocido como colesterol bueno
el l dl se traslada a través de su
torrente sanguíneo llevando el
colesterol a las células que lo
necesitan
si su cuerpo tiene demasiado ldl este
puede acumularse en las paredes de sus
arterias el ldl y otras sustancias en
sus paredes arteriales forman un
depósito graso llamado placa con el
tiempo la placa puede estrechar la
arteria y reducir el flujo sanguíneo el
ld le lleva colesterol a la placa es por
esta razón que el ldl el llamado
colesterol malo un lugar común en donde
se puede acumular esta placa es en sus
arterias coronarias que son los vasos
sanguíneos que alimentan su corazón esta
acumulación de placa provoca cardiopatía
coronaria e incrementa el riesgo de
sufrir un ataque cardíaco la acumulación
de placa en otras arterias como las
arterias carótidas en su cuello pueden
reducir el flujo sanguíneo hacia su
cerebro e incrementar el riesgo de un
accidente cerebrovascular su hígado
también produce lipoproteínas de alta
densidad hdl también conocido como
colesterol bueno
el hdl ayuda a eliminar el exceso de
colesterol de sus células tejidos y de
placa en sus vasos sanguíneos este es el
motivo por el cual el hdl es llamado
colesterol bueno el hdl devuelve el
exceso de colesterol a su hígado el cual
lo elimina de su cuerpo
si después de ver esta información usted
tiene preguntas sobre colesterol
o sobre algún medicamento que le hayan
recetado para controlar sus niveles
altos de colesterol comuníquese con su
proveedor de atención médica es
importante que tome sus medicamentos
según lo establecido por su proveedor
y que informe sobre cualquier efecto
secundario que experimente